foreign
[Music]
questions
hey everyone uh it's Palm Sunday please
go wait in the lobby and uh for further
instructions except for the band
everyone else who's in here should be in
the lobby
[Music]
doing
something
[Music]
not everybody
thank you
[Music]
Ash do you mind closing that door
that one yeah
[Music]
branches
thank you
[Music]
foreign
people boys
[Music]
thank you
experience
come on over here
thank you
all right welcome welcome
um thank you for being here this is your
first time we don't do this every Sunday
um
[Applause]
thank you for joining us this Palm
Sunday it is Palm Sunday thus the Palms
if you're not familiar with the
tradition this is uh the day where
Christ entered Jerusalem and if you know
the story the crowds they were shouting
you know Hosanna bless this you comes
the name of the Lord and they laid the
palm branches down on the ground of
course in that day he wasn't you know
riding the donkey in on cement in a nice
Road it was like mud and stuff so you
would write and kind of um clear the way
right so um in a sense that's sort of
what where hey
um so that's that's sort of the
tradition in what we're commemorating
this of course also begins
um Holy Week as we come into Good Friday
and then on to Easter Sunday next week
so
um
with all that being said tonight
um what I want to do I want to read a
portion of Psalm 118.
and there's a little phrase that's his
love endures forever and I'm going to
intersperse that throughout so whenever
I put my hand up like that you all can
say
y'all are so good at this I think you
would be so um and then what we're gonna
do after that I'm going to kind of lead
the way and we will March in it's like
if you weren't a theater kid growing up
it's just you know you gotta get in the
spirit like you can yell out praise the
Lord or Hosanna
adults did it just let the kids do it
but you can't do that
give thanks to the Lord for he is good
at the beginning
let Israel
says
open for me the gates of the righteous I
will enter and give thanks to the Lord
and this is the Gate of the Lord through
which the righteous may enter
I will give you thanks for you answer me
you have become my salvation the stone
the builders rejected has become the
Cornerstone the Lord has done this and
it is marvelous in our eyes
the Lord has done it this very day let
us rejoice today and be glad Lord save
us Lord grant us success blessed is he
who comes the name of the Lord from the
house of the Lord we bless you
the Lord is God and he has made his life
Shine On Us with vowels in hand join in
the festival procession up to the horns
of the altar you are my God and I will
praise you you are my God and I will
exalt you give thanks to the Lord for he
is good forever
are you ready
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
again
[Music]
[Applause]
alive
[Music]
today
foreign
[Music]
closing down
hosanna in the heart last time
[Music]
you guys feel free to stand and sing
along as we enter in continue to worship
[Music]
Praises
Rising
the eyes are turning to you
[Music]
anymore
we long for you
cause when we see you we find straight
to face the day
in your presence
[Music]
amazing is Jose
I need
we turn to you
[Music]
in your
kingdom
broken lives
[Music]
today
in your presence all our fears are
washed away
I washed away
today
you are the God who saves us
[Music]
cause when we see you we find strength
to face the day
[Music]
and in your presence so love fields are
washed away
I washed away stick it out
you are the God who saves us
worthy of all our praises
we welcome you here Lord Jesus
foreign
good job you guys you kiddos thanks for
leading Us in with so much energy
um we're gonna go ahead and release you
guys to our classrooms and preschool and
Kinder kids if you guys will follow your
teacher into this classroom on your
right and first through fifth graders
line up at the classroom here on your
left your teachers are going to let you
in and I just want to shout out to Kelly
Anna Devin Chrissy Alina thank you guys
so so much for the ways that you serve
our kids and our church community so
grateful for you guys thank you
and then we're going to go ahead and
enter into the prayers of the people if
this is your first time with us this is
a tradition
um throughout Christian history and um
we're going to begin by reading a prayer
out loud together and then we'll leave
space for you to say a name or situation
that you would like to hold up in prayer
before God and we just want to do this
as a practice each week for us to make
space for what's going on in each one of
our Lives because we all walk through
these doors with a different story and
different situations and we want to
acknowledge that and we want to give
space to name those things because this
is not a church where we're asking you
to show up and pretend like everything's
going great when it's not because
sometimes things are really crappy and
sometimes we need space to name that
together and and for us to also remember
those who are hurting the people that
we're carrying close in our hearts or
the situations that are burdening us and
so this is just a time for us to lift
those up together so we encourage you
guys to just join in with us if you're
online you can leave your comment there
and we will share those with the room
for anyone who wants to join in in that
way so let's read this prayer aloud
together
for the city of Sachse Texas and for
every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you
for The Good Earth you have given us and
the wisdom and the will to conserve it
we pray to you for the old and the sick
for the Widow and orphan for the injured
and suffering we pray to you for the
poor and the oppressed the unemployed
and destitute for prisoners and captives
and all who remember and care for them
we pray to you for the vulnerable the
marginalized and those unjustly targeted
for their gender sexuality race or other
perceived difference we pray to you for
those experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you
Lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us so we lift these names and
situations up to you
[Music]
radio
for those who have been impacted by the
shootings
for the names and moments that we have
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts we pray to you that
they may have life and light healing and
Hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
[Music]
foreign
we'll make all things new
we'll make all things
new
will make all things new
[Music]
just one touch
and Everything
Changes
Everything Changes
[Music]
one word
the world
rearranges the world rearranges
[Music]
one life
death Was Defeated death was defeated
[Music]
foreign
oh there's
the miracle maker
Miracle maker
[Music]
Jesus
nothing and No One Compares
[Music]
[Applause]
no one like you
[Music]
Just One Touch
everything
[Music]
foreign
Jesus
[Applause]
[Music]
I just want to touch
and Everything Changes
Everything Changes
[Music]
that today we celebrate a gospel
where forgiveness and Redemption and
hope are possible
[Music]
we celebrate a God who came Among Us
who walked to our path
[Music]
celebrate God With Us
not separate from us
not looking down on us
but a God who loves
a God who knows our struggles
[Music]
and who makes room for our stories
foreign
thank you for who you are
would it be real in our lives
would it change us from the inside out
would we be better because of this
gospel story
would we have a hope because of it
[Music]
in Jesus name we pray all these things
amen
[Music]
thank you guys so much if you want to
turn to the people around you welcome
them make them feel at home and then we
will get started with our message
oh Grace and peace welcome welcome to
the table
um my name is Brett I'm a pastor here
and it is it's so good to be with you
all and uh I I was thinking about Palm
Sunday last year this was the last year
was really our first time
um to celebrate Palm Sunday as a church
the community we started three years ago
of course but um between covid and in
some other things we just hadn't ever
you know really done that and in the
church I came from we didn't really do
Palm Sunday so it's been like so many
years um and so last year I loved like
doing the whole thing walking around
with you know it was just uh it was it
was just uh fascinating and wonderful
and um but afterwards one of my uh one
of my kid was Dex my oldest boy he said
um because that was his first Palm
Sunday too he said Dad
do you think if someone visited our
church and like I didn't really know
about like church or you know the story
or anything and they just this is like
just for Palm Sunday do you think that
they would think that we're a cult
but welcome welcome I'm really yeah just
glad that you're you're all here and
um you know this is like I mentioned out
out
um in the lobby narthex I don't know
everyone has their terms for that area
the church is um but uh I I just
mentioned that you know this is the
beginning of Holy Week and um so I just
I encourage you all to to be really
um I don't know just kind of in tune you
know if you've kind of felt distant from
God
um for a while this would be a great
week to like engage whether it's just at
whatever level you feel like you can
whether it's reading the scriptures or
saying a prayer
um or attending like we will have the
Good Friday service um here Friday night
at Seven it'll be a really we're joining
in with Pleasant Valley United Methodist
whose space we rent for that service
um so I'll do some of the scripture
readings and things but um but it's just
it'll be I think a really beautiful
meaningful
um time and then of course Easter Sunday
will be here next week um bright and
early because we rent we need to be
before their service it's gonna be eight
o'clock
we will have breakfast for you so you
know
um but uh yeah but it should just be a
really really meaningful time so all
that to say I encourage you to
um yeah just be here if you be present
this week so um all right let's get into
it the title of my message this this
Palm Sunday is uh getting lower
getting lower and I want to read the the
scripture this is Matthew 21. verses 1
through 11. it says as they approach
Jerusalem and came to Bethpage on the
Mount of Olives Jesus and two disciples
saying to them go to the Village ahead
of you and at once you will find a
donkey tight there with her cult by her
untie them and bring them to me
if anyone says anything to you say that
the Lord needs them and he will send
them right away this took place through
the Ville was spoken through the prophet
say to daughter Zion C your king comes
to you Gentle in riding on a donkey and
on a cult the full of a donkey verse six
the disciples went and did as Jesus had
instructed them they brought the donkey
and the Colts and placed their cloaks on
them for Jesus to sit on
a very large crowd spread their cloaks
on the road while others cut branches
from the trees and spread them on the
road the crowds that went ahead of him
and those that followed shouted Hosanna
to the son of David blessed is he who
comes in the name of the Lord blessed in
the highest heaven when Jesus entered
Jerusalem the whole city was Stir and
they all asked who is this the crowds
answered this is Jesus the prophet from
Nazareth in Galilee
so that's the story
and uh Palm Sunday it's a it's a kind of
a curious interesting day because on the
one hand it was very much I think the
vibe of what we all just enacted you
know it's I mean it's joyous and people
are shouting you know it's happy things
but
it's bloodhousing or all the things
um and yet there is a certain
you might call like an ironic tension uh
because there is the question of uh
why like why are they cheering
um
do they do they see Jesus as he actually
is or do they see him as they want to
see him
um not as he
really
is like in other words are they
embracing
um like God's ways that God's kingdom
and God's heart for the world or is it a
little bit uh you might say like a
little bit squirrely you know like a
little bit like what are the what are
the motives here
um in essence like are they projecting
their own kind of hopes and dreams and
longings then in in good ways and in
like not so good ways right some of
that's in alignment with who he is and
like maybe other parts of it not so much
um
and that's kind of the the tension of of
this day you know it's a bit unclear and
I guess in many ways it's really not
like two different
um from like many of us today you know I
think we could all and not in like a
judgmental way but in a you know I think
even as we can all look back on seasons
of kind of our our own spiritual life
you know and you kind of asked the
question like what was that about
exactly why was I there you know like
what why was I in that church Community
why what
what were my motives you know in this
sort of a mixed bag I think for any of
us we can kind of get I don't know if
you're like me you can kind of get
overly in your head about like yeah what
are my motives I don't even you know
um you know so we can kind of rely I'm
not trying to stress this out but in a
you know an honest way I think there's
there's um you know there's a lot going
on in this uh I don't know this human
heart in mind and often the motives are
I think a mixed bag you know I don't
know for some people could be like on
the one hand we do have like a hunger
for God you know and then there's also
like but also I want to make my parents
proud you know or whatever like
someone else I jotted a few other ones
down oh just like a bomb for our
conscience
you know um which isn't all bad
the the things that draw us here you
know maybe a way to get like God on our
side or even kind of writ large like a
way to get God on our community or our
tribe side you know to like feel that
kind of like that feels good
um so yeah it's kind of a mixed bag and
um the thing is though even in in like
in this story Jesus doesn't say anything
I mean it's like he talks to the Cycles
but I'm saying in the entrance you know
he's just everyone's shouting and he's
just quiet you know but even in the
entrance to Jerusalem
um you can already see like there's
there's signs that him and the crowds
there may not be the alignment that they
are like hoping for in other words he
may not be the king that they want
he just may be the king they need
uh but it's different
you know and um you know in other words
like thinking of how that plays out he
is the king what will he do he will go
to the Cross which is quite unforeseen
by them you know those Crowds Are Not
imagining like oh yes you know this is
where the story's going you know
um he's gonna go to the Cross there's
gonna be death there's gonna be then
Resurrection
um
he will
um give them an entirely new way of
being in the world he will then launch a
community that is at least at its best
supposed to be a community that loves
the poor and the marginalized a
community that enacts a kingdom of love
and Outreach and radical hospitality and
welcome I mean this is this is what he's
inaugurating this is what he's
initiating this is the movement he's
getting going
um but you know to what degree do they
they realize that
um I don't think they're quite tracking
because you see
um I think in that moment probably what
they're thinking if you know some of the
historical contexts they the Jewish
people at that time had been it was
basically one conquest after another if
you know the history there was like the
um Babylonian conquest and then the
Assyrian conquest of Jerusalem and the
whole surrounding region and then um you
had the Persian conquest and the Romans
were like the latest Conquest so
probably
you know when they're shouting Hosanna
you know blessed is he who comes in the
name of the Lord you know probably what
they're imagining is like he's here the
Conqueror he's here but I said earlier
they should have tuned in because um you
noticed what he rode in on and that's
really key to the story it wasn't
unusual in that ancient world for a king
to
um like enter even a conquering king
after
maybe you know having some sort of War
would enter the city it'd be like a
whole parade and that that king would of
course ride on a war horse
and so you can you can kind of see where
this is going right what was it did you
just say go grab the uh the war horses
from the King Stables you know and bring
the swords extra Spears you know uh no
it wasn't quite like that was it it's
like the a little a donkey
um this kind of Beast of Burden
and so it's you can already see it it
happening and in fact the story we read
a few minutes ago that's from The Gospel
Matthew and then it quotes a passage
from Zachariah which I want to read it's
only two verses um though they're kind
of lengthy but this kind of really fills
out the picture so this is in essence
this was written by the way hundreds of
years before Christ so it seems to be
sort of a prophetic kind of a picture of
who Christ would be uh and so the
prophet Zechariah wrote these words
Rejoice greatly daughter Zion shout
daughter Jerusalem see your king comes
to you righteous and Victorious so
you're kind of getting a feel here you
know of like yes this is what we're
talking about what are the next words
you can already see them up there uh
slowly
in writing on a donkey on a cult the
fool of a donkey I will take away the
Chariots from Ephraim the war horses
from Jerusalem
and can you kind of see the imagery I
know it doesn't totally apply like in
our context it could be like uh I will I
don't know like I'll I'll disable all
the tanks
you know is this sort of this image of
Peace you know which I don't know maybe
we wouldn't be so comfortable with that
you know
um the battle bow will be broken all the
rifles
taken down maybe I shouldn't preach such
things in Texas a little dangerous
he will Proclaim peace to the Nations
his rule will extend from sea to Sea
from the river to the ends of the Earth
so in other words it seems that um you
see Christ entered Jerusalem not riding
a war horse but a donkey
which means not in arrogance
but in humility
not bringing violence
but peace
that's the message that's the heart of
of what this day is about and that's the
heart of who Christ was
and maybe I don't know how that strikes
you you know maybe
maybe it feels a little strange like ah
well I don't know I wanted him to be
awesome you know and he's like sort of I
don't know like he enters Jerusalem is
like this little weakling or something
like no
um I mean you notice the language right
uh verse nine c your king comes to you
righteous and Victorious and yet lowly
right so you can kind of see the
juxtaposition there he's
glorious and yet he's lowly
he's a conqueror yet he's humble the
people are shouting yet he's quiet and
they'd probably soon expect violence but
what does Zechariah say he's not
bringing violence is he he's bringing
peace in fact he allows him to enact a
violence upon his very body
uh it's a different can you see where
the the ironic tension I named earlier
it's sort of building throughout the the
story
um so he's not the king you might even
say he's not the like the god that we
often at least that are worse that
really really want
um but he's the king the god that we
need and what do I mean by that I'm just
imagining like
you know how do we image God how do we
understand who God is I would say often
um
we sort of image God like if it were
left up to our egos
and this often plays out you can see
there's a lot of God talk out there
you've probably noticed
um you know what what kind of God is
being described
is does it sound like this does it sound
like Christ or is it like some
or no one else
um because if we just leave our own
image of God kind of to an idol of our
own fashioning
um I think it's it's often like a god
who's sort of to use a metaphor sort of
a muscular God like he's gonna he's
gonna fight for us and he's gonna be on
our side and he's gonna slay our enemies
and be opposed to everyone that that we
hate he's gonna love everyone we love
and uh you know and he's the king and
we're the King's kids so you can even
see where some of this theology starts
getting it gets a little wild like you
know we're the King's kids so all the
good if you uh if you write out a big
you know check to this ministry you will
prosper you know this kind of ideas like
it becomes this uh this sort of
prosperity you know like like we're
gonna we're gonna flourish we're gonna
flourish you know economically and
socially and politically and and you
just get on board with the kingdom of
God and then you're the King's kids and
the King's kids get all the good things
you know it's sort of you can see where
this goes and um
you know needless to say uh there's a
kernel of Truth in a sense of yes God
wants us to flourish and be blessed and
you know but it's just obviously it's
not always
um always in the ways that we that we
want right so often again at our worst I
think that's the God we want like yeah
I'm here for that I want to win I want
to be on the Winner's side
um
but uh thanks be to God sometimes it's a
blessing not to get what uh what you
think you want because it's not what you
need and thanks be to God that in Jesus
Christ this is not who God has been
revealed to be it's not the god that
we've received he doesn't enter our
lives or others lives on a war horse he
enters on a donkey that is to say he
comes in low
he enters with
peace and humility
um and you know I know I'm learning I'm
still learning how to do this
how to live in these ways and and others
I know are still learning too I I think
of a friend I've been in I've had a
number of
stops in like higher education or
whatever and so I went to Bible colleges
I don't know that was what I did back in
my in my young days and uh and so I can
remember there's interesting people
there at bible college some of the
beautiful souls then you know
we're all in a process and I can think
of you know um I can think of one friend
in particular she um
when she became a Christian and you know
I think we often have this sort of image
of like what happens when you become a
Christian there's like a trajectory that
we sort of Envision you know it's sort
of like uh like you're you know you're
messed up you're all messed up and then
you get saved and then
ah you're set free and everything's
great you know um and it's sort of
overly simplistic and uh and the
trajectory is always you know onward and
upward sort of like yes and it's not
like that you know it's messy and it was
interesting
um well and I should name that's not
just true for others I think that's true
for all of us I understand the language
of like being saved
um and there's truth in that sense but
there's also something about
um that as like an ongoing thing I think
we are all of us always being safe not
just saved I'm saved done you know but
it's that's what the Bible talks about a
sanctification this this ongoing healing
that happens in all of us so
um to get back to my story this I think
that was still going on you know like it
is for me but it was really going on for
her and
um she was
um kind of what happened was I noticed
she got saved you know quote unquote and
then she got worse
and I don't mean just like oh you know
she has some suffering and some bad
things happened in her life I mean like
like
um
she as a person less kind
less loving less compassionate like to
think of the fruits of the spirit you
know Galatians 5 22 23 you know love joy
peace patience kindness goodness Jonas
faithfulness self-control it was sort of
like a lot of that sort of getting uh to
use that word again it's so weird I
shouldn't use this for squirrely I like
it tonight I don't know I'm just gonna
go with it I'm just rolling with
squirrely it just things started getting
support
so kind of what happened was
what business is what happened she
became a Christian and she got the truth
she got the truth
and you know it wasn't she got you know
the truth
you know I mean that wasn't that wasn't
the emotional heart posture was it she
got the truth and I want to share this
truth this beauty you know the goodness
of God you know no it wasn't quite like
that it was she got the truth
and now if it was like this you know and
she was gonna wield it like a sword
you know mowing down the unbelievers and
the people who disagreed with her
theology this is sort of the you know
there's the beautiful things of
such religious institutions Bible
colleges and then there's like the other
Shadow sides you know this is the shadow
side she would you know wield that that
sword and uh I don't know obviously it's
a metaphor yeah I'm talking
intellectually emotionally
verbally just shopping
uh with anyone in everyone
who disagreed with her
the trick was of course that it was all
for you know the good of the Kingdom
what was happening what was she missing
I think it's the hard truth of Palm
Sunday see the truth of Palm Sunday is
not only that oh you know oh good for
Jesus he enters lowly and humbly riding
on a donkey
he comes in humility right it's not just
that what's the message of Palm Sunday
church we are called to do the same
that's the trick
and that's where you might say the
rubber meets the road that's where it
gets hard because it's easy to be like
yeah Jesus is so great only look Jesus
wonderful so humble and I just love they
didn't ride the war horse you know and
it's like that's easy to you know kind
of like yes you do that Jesus it's just
it gets harder when it's like you know
when it's personal
um you know in essence
I think what I'm driving at to kind of
draw to a close like we are called to be
the peace people
peace people we are not at War
with our you know pick your group like
our our unbelieving neighbors or people
of different religious Traditions
um we are not at war with with those um
on the other side of the political aisle
Christ did not not enter our lives on a
war horse he entered in humility
laying down his life going to the cross
and so the hard truth is we are called
to do the same
and so in essence oh
we inter lowly
we enter lowly that's why the title
message is is getting lower church
that's the call get lower and then when
you think you've gone as low as you can
get lower still
do you want to connect with people
get lower
do you want to reconnect with those your
utterly alienated and estranged from
get lower
do you want to bring people to Christ in
a beautiful
compelling way
not like
mowing them down you know
get lower get lower and what do I mean
by get lower a few things number one
getting lower means embracing humility
which doesn't mean becoming a doormat
you know but it means because you're
loved because you're secured
in securing yourself and in The God Who
is love you know you're loved then you
can just be yourself
just be yourself vulnerable honest real
like yep these are my strengths these
are my weaknesses this is who I am
you know there's that's what it getting
lower means it means embracing peace
which I won't go into because you've
kind of heard it throughout this message
you know not violence not force forcing
badgering you know but but loving
embracing generosity there's something
about giving and it could be financially
it could be time energy but just giving
that is
um is a form of getting lower right
because the opposite of that is like I
want to get you know that's not good you
know but to but to give
um and then finally embracing
forgiveness
you might say to Bear a grudge
human
to forgive divine
so I wonder how many of the world's
problems could be solved if we could all
commit to get lower not an insecure
grovelry kind of way but really in the
opposite spirit
you might say that that our call is to
say I too will ride donkeys not war
horses I too will seek to make peace
rather than conflict I too will be
humble rather than arrogant I too will
make room for others I too will get low
in the name of the Father the Son and
the Holy Spirit
amen
so um
we're going to come to the table of the
Lord tonight
and
um you know as we do that I want us to
do it in a spirit of
just being open to what God's saying to
us and and really maybe it might even
just be a simple prayer of asking um God
like maybe there's places in your life
where you've been riding that War Horse
you know
um and asking God to do a work in your
own heart and mind as we all seek to get
lower as we approach Holy Week
so um tonight as we take the body of
Christ in the bread the blood of Christ
and the wine I encourage you to just be
open yeah to what God's up to in your
life and you might wonder like oh what
are the rules am I allowed to go forward
you know whatever
um just know we practice what's called
an Open Table meaning if you're here
tonight and you would like to
participate
you are free
we're free to do that there's something
in you that that longs to connect with
Christ then you're free to come forward
um
the white is grape juice the red is wine
and the bread is gluten free
and the way we'll do this we're gonna my
walk off
back in Aaron are going to come forward
and um you oh we'll just kind of form a
line right here and we usually just kind
of dismiss almost by row by row so it
just as the people on the row in front
of you have gone that you can just get
up and join the line and and partake
just whenever you would like no one will
like come up and say you know when to
eat and such just um you can take it
immediately you can return to your seat
say a prayer and then partake there
um however you'd like to engage it so
let me welcome you with this this Celtic
Christian invitation this is the table
not of the church
[Music]
but of the Lord and it's made ready for
those who love him and for those who
want to love him more so come you have
much faith in you who have little you
who have been here often and you who
have not been here long
you who have tried to follow in you who
have failed come
because it's the Lord Jesus himself who
invites you and it's his will that those
who want to meet him should meet him
here come to the table
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
we're going to close out with a song
called Poor and Powerless and I love
what Brett was talking about and
um
the ways that that
kind of like
is becomes meat in our lives instead of
just something nice that we say is
um
when I Envision the people that Jesus is
on the side of
and so often I have to remind myself
that it's not the people that I Envision
in my mind
left to my own devices I can you know
definitely go down a very self-righteous
path and I love how Jesus reminds me
that he's on the side of the broken and
the Prisoner and
um
and the ones that I would discount he
he is a God that's on our side and so
tonight as we sing these words
I I'm just gonna Envision this God that
we serve coming on a donkey
and people who are poor people who have
zero power zero voice him writing in for
them
for us in our lowly estate when we are
full of Shame and sin or hurt pain
he is writing for us
so if you guys want to stand and sing
this with us I just feel like it's a
beautiful way for us to close out our
Palm Sunday service
[Music]
please
and All That You Are Holy
[Music]
and all we'll see
with all the hearts you are contained
[Music]
and all the feeling Worthy
we know
[Music]
we'll see we go honey
shouting
go on and screaming from the mountains
[Music]
that he
foreign
good morning screaming from the
mountains
[Music]
many years
only
with me
[Music]
don't leave me alone
go on and screaming from the mind
mountains
go on and tell it to the Man
says
that he is
[Music]
so it's been kind of an interesting week
it's a very handy base and kind of
in between the actual shooting some
additional verdicts that have been
placed on our trans community
and that can kind of weigh on us
especially with our community so I've
said this before I will continue saying
this again if you need any kind of
support of listening here a hug or
something to that effect I will be in
the back for any of those things
[Music]
paying attention to the weather because
we are so we are expected to have our
first
first family bill at hack Creek it looks
like the weather is going to hold up
so please please please join us at hack
Creek
on another great place to connect with
each other to share
for each other
[Music]
it's right kind of where you're
mentioned is Easter weekend
[Music]
and we'll be here for them
also if you did
um Easter eggs thank you so much for
bringing those of you looking forward to
do that the nooshi donation boxes
outside please drop that off on your way
out if you still want to continue to do
that please get rid of Maggie she'll
probably because definitely want to take
the news before next week
and before we head out I do want to send
you out with this benediction
[Music]
so you are a child of God
you are a child of God
and this is true on your best day and is
true on your worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
this yet determined highs and lows and
everything in between
go deal with the insurance that you were
loved that you you're worthy and you are
accepted just as you are
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend it these same gifts
that I of Grace and unconditional love
with everyone you come in contact with
thank you
[Music]
and we will see
[Applause]
[Music]
we will see
thank you